with aaron donald is that a situation
where
you guys want to get him as much rest as
possible
this week and then um you know you're
still optimistic that he'll be able to
go on saturday
yeah he's feeling really good you know
we're just going to really rest him the
whole week and
be as smart as possible i mean he was
just in there getting a workout in the
weight room and he looked like he's
feeling pretty good to me so
unless something unforeseen happens
jordan the terminator will be ready
oh okay well we lost florio so it's
gonna be all me this segment the
terminator
will be ready to go i'm betting on that
certainly aaron donald are you kidding
me
for the los angeles rams that's big for
they need him healthy ready to go
i think that's going to be a really big
talking point as we go into this
football game
the rams that packers offense it's one
of the best in football
everything they do there they need a guy
like aaron donald
you know this is a packers offense that
can run it
throw it at will right now they are a
better offense than last year going into
the playoffs
and the rams who are awesome defense
will certainly need aaron donald at full
strength hey nice to have you back
thanks for showing up for work
good to be back yeah thank you i i had
some sort of a power outage but we're
fine now
i was just getting ready to make some
sort of a smart ass comment about
sean mcvay's hair what the hell was that
i i i don't i
i like it it looked like a grown-up
jimmy neutron initially
and then if you look at it the right way
and chris this is before your time have
you ever seen close encounters
uh i feel like i have i remember the
name of that
can we put that it that's the thing
that's the vision that richard dreyfus
had in close encounters
where it was the mountain devil's peak
or something like that where the aliens
showed up
that's the hairstyle that's the devil's
peak hairstyle
for sean mcvay the vision that richard
dreif has had
in close encounters i'm guessing never
seen let me tell you if you've never
seen close encounters
watch it today not right now watch us
for the next hour
but watch it today okay all right so
back to football thank you for that
movie review but the i can't you the
advisor
put something like that he had a visor
on it it's not really i don't it's not
that complicated
later on but let's talk about eric goff
and john wolford because that's
to me interesting i mean there it was
jared goff won the game on sunday
sean mcvay has not wanted to commit
still
here as of wednesday to say he's the guy
i just think that speaks volumes too
they're very excited about you know
heard some miked up sessions from him in
the game last week about what john
wolford can do
for their football team and i think if
there's a chance he can go or maybe
practice
maybe he still could be the starter
there with the rams but i think that's
very
interesting to watch hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports